extraordinary developments in
afghanistan the u.s says it's sending
some 3 000 troops to help evacuate
embassy staff in kabul the decision
comes with the beleaguered afghan
government struggling to turn the tide
against a relentless taliban offensive
the uk is also sending soldiers to help
british nationals leave the country the
taliban are on the march across
afghanistan and appear to have taken
control of herat the country's third
largest city that comes hot on the heels
of militants over running the strategic
town of ghazni just 150 kilometers south
from the capital kabul heavy fighting is
also taking place in kandahar the
country's second biggest city the us
believes the afghan capital itself could
come under attack by the taliban within
weeks and is now asking its citizens to
leave the country immediately
the taliban triumphant in ghazni just
one of a string of provincial capitals
to fall to the militants
they've met barely any resistance it
seems that without backing from us and
other international troops afghan
government forces are reluctant to make
a stand
our security forces are still fighting
the opposition in some areas
but most of ghazni province is under the
total control of the taliban enemy
ghazni lies on a vital highway
connecting the major cities of mazari
sharif in the north and kandahar in the
south both already under heavy attack by
the taliban
and just a short distance from ghazni is
the capital kabul itself
we remain optimistic but we were always
concerned that if the central and local
governments did not pay special
attention to ghazni and it fell
we would see a huge security challenge
threatening kabul
now ghazni has fallen giving the
militants a route straight to kabul and
wherever they take ground they usually
find stockpiles of weapons and vehicles
left behind by fleeing government troops
this video appears to show the taliban
releasing army soldiers who surrendered
further north in kunduz
the militants claim the troops then
joined their ranks but neither the
images nor the information can be
verified
there is no doubt however that the
militants are rapidly gaining ground
and they may yet prove unstoppable
well let's talk to bradley bowman he's
with the center on military and
political power at the foundation for
defence of democracies he joins us from
washington welcome to the program a
string of provincial capitals are being
captured employees from the u.s embassy
in kabul have now been told to leave
are you surprised at the sheer speed at
which this is now unfolding
thanks for the opportunity to join you
and thanks for the question it's
certainly a devastating catastrophe that
we are witnessing unfold in afghanistan
many of us have warned the bite
administration against implementing a
timeline-based conditions ignoring
withdrawal
based on this idea of endless wars that
we've heard so many pundits and
politicians push for so long this is
what you get when you do a conditions
ignoring withdrawal we've seen 12
provincial capitals fall in seven days
more than one-third of afghanistan's
provincial capitals have fallen within a
week
more vulnerable than ever
our national security and my view should
be based on facts on the ground and our
enemies don't stop fighting just because
we withdraw and and what we're seeing
right now is a vivid and sad example of
this the victims in the short term are
going to be afghans particularly afghan
women and girls we're all going to be
victims in the long run because we know
that problems in afghanistan don't stay
there
as the regional cities started to fall
you were quoted earlier this week as
saying the situation in afghanistan was
a predictable disaster what do you now
predict is going to happen in kabul
your predictions are dangerous in
afghanistan but uh you know i would have
if you'd asked me months ago
you know i i warned by administration
not to proceed with after the april 14th
announcement they've done so anyways i
would have predicted that you would have
seen uh significant taliban gains in the
south and the west based on traditional
strengths there the big surprise has
been the gains in the north the large
majority of the provincial capitals that
have fallen have been in the north and
the reason why that's significant for
your viewers is that's the traditional
political strength strong points if you
will of the kabul government badakshan
and other areas like that are either
controlled or contested by the taliban
so clearly the taliban is trying to
isolate the kabul government and
overthrow it and they've been pursuing
this rural strategy that that frankly
the department of defense kind of
ignored for too long and they've now
surrounded the cities and and they're
going into action meanwhile the biden is
ignoring this and withdrawing uh and uh
and and and the really we should be
honest is the us-led nato withdrawal
that has catalyzed what we're seeing now
and it's absolutely sad and tragic
and with that said u.s president joe
biden has doubled down on his decision
saying afghans need to quote fight for
their nation
they've received training from american
and german troops equipment too over the
course of 20 years what more could have
been done to protect them
we had 3 500 troops in afghanistan give
or take in april 3
500 american troops with roughly double
that number of nato troops for 3 500
troops we had we were preventing another
911 attack we were preserving the gains
that afghan women and girls have made
and we were preventing massive new
refugee flows that were going to
destabilize nuclear and pakistan we had
26 000 american troops on capitol hill
after january 6. 3 500 troops was not an
unreasonable investment despite that
biden doubled down on his mistake in the
obama ministration from 2011 in iraq
they conducted a conditions ignoring
withdrawal there and then we got we got
isis and had to go back in 2014. he's
repeating that exact same mistake now in
afghanistan and i fear we're all going
to pay a price
bradley bowman senior director of the
center on military and political power
at the foundation for defence of
democracies thanks for your time
thank you
well the relentless advance of the
taliban has forced thousands of afghans
to flee many have sought safety in the
capital kabul while others are hoping to
leave the country entirely
they fled the taliban's brutal advance
since may more than 220 000 afghans have
been forced to abandon their homes and
seek shelter in other parts of the
country
others are desperate to get out
at the border with pakistan afghans are
waiting for a crossing to reopen
it's just one of many barriers they face
at this point we're primarily worried
that afghans are actually going to get
stuck in afghanistan if taliban controls
border crossings for example if
neighboring countries are effectively
shutting their borders like for example
turkey did towards iran and of course
also the eu has really strengthened
their fortress as we've always already
called it fortress europe and they
really made sure
that they work with their partners who
then in order try to block their borders
and which really then keeps people
unfortunately in an area they are not
safe in
the situation in afghanistan has
prompted some to raise the specter of
the summer of 2015 when germany took in
a million people seeking refuge
mostly from war-torn syria
but a repeat of those events is unlikely
after pressure from eu ambassadors in
afghanistan germany has now suspended
deportations of rejected afghan asylum
seekers
but only temporarily
germany and europe's new focus lies in
keeping those fleeing from getting to
europe by supporting third-party
countries who will host them
that position is unlikely to change as
olaf schultz chancellor candidate for
the social democrats told us
many countries aren't governed the same
way we would expect in germany but they
do offer protection that's why there
need to be prospects for integration in
those countries in africa asia and south
america and we need to share
responsibility
one group that the german government has
vowed to help are afghans who worked
with german troops stationed in the
country and who now face acute danger
but despite promises the process of
getting them to safety has been slow
and as the taliban capture more and more
territory many of them may not get out
before it's too late
you